the Joe Rogan experience so me show me a
tweet I made recently a year ago I'm
like how did we get from Burt can run a
marathon to all gonna go straight edge
for a month he couldn't do it faster
than your dad yeah Holocaust survivor
and then he was but he was also like I
could run marathon tomorrow kind of did
yeah you did I technically did I did
blow the doors off you guys you were
really real amazed but I think the real
test was that tom was gonna try to
roller skate a marathon but he didn't
take an account going uphill or the fact
that he is never roller skated yeah but
that's easy to learn but for us
what do you think would have happened on
the roller skating part of it after
running at marathon yeah you were to
crush dude I think you probably beat me
yeah it was a flat hold on LA Marathon
was uphill downtown but once you got
past the store you would have been
hauling [ __ ] ass down La Cienega yeah
it would never call from the from cellar
to the no be yeah a couple roller
skating people reached out to me and
they were like the hill like you know
they said like your feet are gonna
you're gonna be in rough [ __ ] it's
not it was cold
we're warriors I get it from people that
have been doing it for years and also
like was that the roller derby people
they were like yeah you gotta be careful
well just think about skiing for five
hours if you know great as that would be
yeah you want to ski for five hours
straight without going up lift hills
going to lifts oh yeah up the hills if
you just skied oh we only on your feet
for five hours I bet you'd be hurting
yeah oh yeah anyway it's muscles all
sore yeah you my feet are always hurting
after a day of skiing like Jesus yeah
yeah no it would have been I would have
been [ __ ] up first you got [ __ ] up
did you see me crash Burt didn't know
yeah I did I did and then I pulled up
and you were like oh I don't think it's
broken
[Music]
broken is it
put a pin in it this is all cast I saw
you we have the big wealthy yeah it's
down to this now we show up you got pin
in there like a metal piece broke off I
have some sort of pin you know what's
good about that give one more reason to
[ __ ] with the people at TSA you're
[ __ ] my vasectomy did that like how
come something's going off to everything
you talking like my sex mates like
everything you're talking like vasectomy
like what about belt my vasectomy and
like what what what do you think it's
I'm like I had my dick cut and you're
[ __ ] stupid thing that you're the
head of this company decided we need to
buy it points out that I got a vasectomy
really how does it know you had a
vasectomy because it's a little
inconsistent it's like a hard thing in
there peanut you want to feel it no it's
your choice interesting
so it's calcified yeah I like that yeah
Rockne dick hole yeah so now I'm with
[ __ ] terrorist threat